because we were on Degrassi back in cn4
you put the grass into grass yes what a
great line why did you ever [ __ ] say
that before I went up they just came to
me I'm sorry
[ __ ] that would have been useful now
before we got there like Karina was like
Drake wants you to this is so [ __ ]
strange I was like what are we doing
and she goes Drake wants you guys to do
whatever you want and I'm like oh I was
looking for a little direction man if
you're gonna go someplace else like just
[ __ ] tell me where to stand on what
to do and I'll [ __ ] do it as Silent
Bob right then all of a sudden they'll
like do whatever you want
you gotta come up totally and what if i
disappoint motive might come up with an
idea and he's just like you know
normally I say Yolo but [ __ ] this what I
did not know was how emotional the whole
[ __ ] thing would be all these kids
including Drake they were each other's
high school like they went to school
together mostly there you know and stuff
and some of them went off campus to like
real schools and stuff but they all grew
up together from the time they were like
teens or preteens until the time they
were late teens and left the shells sure
so them coming back to shoot a high
school reunion video wound up being
their high school reunion and all these
kids [ __ ] like each other like it's
not like they're all sitting around
going like [ __ ] him he got famous more
famous than me like I talked to Shane
Kip Lee plays spinner and he's like kind
of the star of the [ __ ] video man it
was so adorable watching him get out of
the [ __ ] Ferrari and [ __ ] like
dressed to the nines I was like oh my
god this is a [ __ ] Degrassi dream
come true finally somebody is lionizing
spin you know so I saw him beforehand
and we were chitchat and catching up and
then Miriam played Emma and Sarah who
played Liberty came in and he was
talking to them going have you guys seen
all brie since we stopped since the you
guys left the show and they were like no
and he goes like this he's good actor he
goes oh man I hate to tell you this but
he is the exact same [ __ ] person
really and it was like oh my god
it's nothing has [ __ ] changed he's
just way richer and so it was really
nice to like hear it and then shortly
thereafter I was out in the parking lot
and he arrived
Drizzy himself with a bunch of folks and
like came over and gave me a big bear
hug and [ __ ] like that and last time I
saw him he was kid this time he was like
taller than me and [ __ ] built and
[ __ ] like that like he gave me a hug and
I felt comforted man like jeez it's like
rock me to sleep man
[Music]
you
[Music]